حاولوا، بالقليل الذي يمكنهم حمله،
الفرار من هان يونس إلى
منطقة أكثر أمانًا لا توجد بها أرض في
غزة. أمرت القوات الإسرائيلية التي تكثف
هجومها ضد حماس
المدنيين بمغادرة الجانب الغربي من
المدينة حيث توجد ثلاثة من آخر
المستشفيات القليلة العاملة في غزة.
تقع هذه المواقع وحيث لجأ آلاف الأشخاص إلى
800 شخص آخرين كانوا
يحتمون في
مركز تدريب مهني تابع للأمم المتحدة، وقد تعرض وفقًا للأمم المتحدة لقصف بقذيفتين من
الدبابات الإسرائيلية،
والحقيقة هي أن هذه الضربات
تضرب منشآت محمية،
ومنشآت محمية، وتضرب
منشآت أخرى.  يسكنون يأوون
مدنيين أو تعرف أين لديك
طواقم طبية أه تهتم
بالجرحى والمصابين والمرضى
هذا الرجل تمكن من الهرب من كان
يونس تحت القصف يسأل
أطفاله هل أكلتم اليوم لا
يستجيبون يحومون فوق عذاب  هذه
الحرب هي شبح المجاعة، يحذر
مايكل فقي في خطاب الأمم المتحدة الخاص بشأن
الحق في الغذاء، كيف تصف
الوضع الغذائي في غزة في الوقت الحالي الذي
يعاني فيه كل شخص في غزة من الجوع،
وهذا يعني أن 2.2 مليون شخص يعانون من
الجوع ربع العام؟  السكان يتضورون
جوعا ويكافحون من أجل العثور على الغذاء
والمياه الصالحة للشرب، والمجاعة
وشيكة منذ أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، وقد أصبحت غزة
أرضا للبدو الرحل الذين يتنقلون من مكان إلى آخر يائسين
مع تحرك الحرب
جنوبا، وقد
فر إليها مئات الآلاف
ويفر المزيد منها كل يوم.  إلى رع على
الحدود المصرية مكتظة الآن بأكثر
من مليون
نازح، ولم يتبق سوى بضع بقع في
الرمال، والمكان الوحيد بعد ذلك هو
البحر. بن ويدمان تقرير سي إن إن من
بيروت